when dr. Fuad enters the wet lab at the
marine science station he knows that the
future of the world's corals is not
guaranteed
so experiments are carried out in these
tanks that take advantage of qualities
found in the red sea where nearly 200
species of hard coral have flourished
this is that is a lot of corals for the
rest of the world what we have done so
far is to start some techniques
collectively we call them cool books for
creating a new coral reef areas one
method involves coral engineering
combining fragments of different species
of coral each resistant to a different
type of disease or other stress factor
within a few years they fuse together
into one creature that's stronger than
any one part a small miracle of nature
all the learning and experimentation
here begins with a basic lesson for us
all many people in the world they do not
realize what is the nature of colors
some people think that those are only
stones present in the sea some others
they think they are plants and they
don't know how much they are fragile and
that's why in many cases they can harm
them without even knowing that they are
killing those creatures Jordan only has
27 kilometres of coastline along the Red
Sea waters of its commercial hub are
shared by Israel Egypt and Saudi Arabia
along with ferries fishermen and
hundreds of thousands of visitors every
year these clear waters are the main
reason why tourists come to the Gulf of
Aqaba and the researchers here are
preparing for the worst they're growing
corals even freezing and storing them
just in case
climate change wipes out threatened
populations this Yellow Turban area is
much bigger than any human gliding past
it bigger corals are found here but this
one is about five centuries old someday
it's hoped the cultured corals will
outlast us all red sea varieties are
proving to be resilient to climate
change and warming seas the scientists
practically boast they'll be the last to
die back in the lab may soon and her
colleagues constantly monitor the reefs
health ensuring that pollutants along
the coastline are not adding stress to
the creatures below too often
development comes with an ecological
cost
Hypersport is that all and frustrated us
to be in contact with coral and when
they are in contact with coral coral
will stressed which is why scientists
say it's crucial to keep them at ease
especially since the reefs are home to a
quarter of all marine life
Andrew Chappell al-jazeera Aqaba